[Music]
so
we do the same thing as we usually do
for the fixed wave so we need to find
five waves so i need to understand what
is happening here so this is
one two then it means i'm in the third
wave i'm in the third wave
then i'm gonna have a fourth and then a
fifth so in my
third wave i try to find five waves one
two
three four my triangle was a four let me
go back on a daily
triangles are always false i mean not
always but
very often when you see a triangle you
can always assume it's a four
it's a fourth wave and third wave are
the most impulsive the strongest so this
is definitely
three this is a four all right so i'm
having a five
so we are having a fixed wave now look
so one two has been used here so this is
my new one two
this is my third all right the strongest
most impulsive this is my fourth
triangle correction so i'm in the fifth
wave fifth swept
are developing in five waves guys so i
cannot count five waves here
one two all right i count this one two
three four so the worst case scenario is
that we are like this
okay so anyway we're gonna go higher so
of course
you sometimes you're gonna actually see
that your counting was wrong if
discounting is wrong
maybe this is won't happen if if my
accounting is correct
this will happen so you need to use
shorter time frame
indicators to see if this makes sense
but for now
this move is not complete for me so
we're gonna go to the next one so the
next one is 75 000
so i think we're going to go to 75 000
and that this is gonna be
something like this all right so then
we're gonna see if this is complete
or not or maybe we're gonna have one
more extension but then then we can have
a scenario like this
so for now i'm bullish but i'm waiting
to have some
more bullish signals let's go very
quickly on the hourly time frame
and now let's try to find some
confirmation
of my theory iliad is giving you the big
picture
so the big picture is we're going to go
first to 77 000
probably before correction now to get
this confirmed i need to see more data
here i need to have more consolidation
and then i need to find a breakout
for now i don't have anything guys let's
be honest i don't have anything
this can correct the only thing let's
try to find some safety life
levels below which we're gonna sell not
easy
i'm trying to look for the moving
averages but none of them is
uh the 200 is quite efficient but here
you have a fake breakout i'm trying to
see if
any moving average is working perfectly
as support during this move up
but i don't see this one has been broken
down
here so if you sell here i mean you're
[ __ ]
so i don't have any safety line i don't
have enough data
this is very messy for me i cannot see
things
clearly the only thing i would see is
this
this 40 42 000 because it's the maximum
that was here
you know so it's a pivot point it has
not been reached
something sorry yeah around here you
know the the lowest level that we had
here
was 43 or at 43 42 000
below that guys careful all right uh
you can buy at 43 000 i think it's a
nice level to buy
i wouldn't know exactly where to put the
stop loss probably 40 000
but then you have more support guys so
maybe in the long term
view you could buy around you know 35
000
because 35 000 was actually the
previous fib extension level
so i think this is the level where it
makes the most sense to make
to build a new long position but once
again you need to
make some short term analysis when the
move
is coming to 35 000 so that's it for me
uh i hope you guys enjoyed this video i
hope i managed to explain
how i actually build my views so i use
idiot and then i go on a shorter time
frame to understand
if my accounting is good or not and if
you did enjoy that please don't forget
to click the sub like and bell button so
you're going to be the first to know
when i upload anything new
and stay close to show i'll see you guys